just how badly is the new mac studio  destroying the mac pro now before we  begin i do want to mention the  difference in prices fifty eight hundred  dollars compared to fifteen thousand  it's safe to say that apple has  completely killed that mac pro for 99  of the workloads out there for sure  especially in terms of the cpu  performance because i feel like the cpu  is being utilized very very well  especially in tasks like logic pro music  production especially xcode especially  photo editing it is just killing it for  those cpu tests but in terms of the gpu  i am a little bit underwhelmed i feel  like apple hasn't fully optimized it or  fully let us use all of the power that  we should but either way it's still  killing the vega 2 graphics card that's  in the mac pro so yeah i mean rip  mac pro that's all i gotta say